let's talk about geopolitics a little
bit I've told you that more and more the
United States under Donald Trump is sort
of less and less a part of important
geopolitical discussions that are going
on so climate change is one example with
climate change I mean just forget about
it why even bother inviting the United
States when Donald Trump claims that
climate change is a hoax like what's the
point of even including the u.s. in the
conversation when it comes to economics
there are other countries that are
having important serious discussions
about economics while Donald Trump is
playing these tariff games with China
and the European Union trumping clear
increasingly not a part of those
discussions and I can give you more
examples but what I want to get to is
something new that's going on there's a
new World Alliance which is specifically
aimed at mitigating the damage that's
being done by the authoritarians and the
autocrats around the world and
reinforcing a sort of cooperative joint
effort spirit that many countries have
subscribed to for decades in sort of
modern geopolitics and this is a crazy
position for the United States to be in
because if you think back to a few years
into Barack Obama's presidency for
example Barack Obama sort of raised the
profile of the United States in the
context of participating in
international efforts on whatever we're
talking about whether it's the climate
whether it's poverty mitigation whether
it's economics whatever the case may be
today as a result of the Trump
administration the United States is more
on the side of the authoritarians and of
the autocrats than of the Western
democracies and more on the side that
opposes international cooperation and
what we're seeing now is that Germany
and France have started this new
coalition Japan joined it Canada joined
it the Coalition exists specifically
because they see American leadership as
having been damaged under Donald Trump
Trump speaking out increasingly against
world institutions like the United
Nations he spoken out against NATO the
World Trade Organization and without
arguing the
those are perfect organizations because
they're not this is very very strange
and it really requires a little bit of
nuance to understand it everything that
the United Nations does isn't perfect
everything that NATO suggests or stands
for is not perfect everything that the
World Trade Organization does isn't
necessarily good for the United States
or even in general for the world but
what you're seeing is that without being
a dictatorship under Trump obviously the
United States is not a dictatorship the
United States is increasingly on the
side of the authoritarians and the
autocrats now I don't want to go
overboard and become hyperbolic the
United States is still one of the
richest countries in the world Trump
hasn't changed that the United States is
still putatively a democracy although as
we know it's the type of democracy that
actually reflects the views of the rich
and of corporations much more than
average people but that's been the case
even since before Trump became president
the United States is still the leader in
innovation in many areas culturally we
continue to export American culture all
over the world Trump for now hasn't
changed that but if we put that aside
for a moment countries that our our our
historical allies and partners like
Japan and France and Canada and Germany
in the United Kingdom they are now
increasingly aligned together not
alongside Donald Trump and instead
Donald Trump is much more partial to the
authoritarian autocrats they're not all
dictators but we're talking about people
like uh dawuan Kim jong-un who is a
dictator Bashar al-assad who is a
dictator the Chinese President Xi of
Vladimir Putin Rodrigo Duterte
and so on Trump has alienated our
historical allies and instead has been
cozying up to the authoritarian so the
question is what are other countries
going to do they're obviously not going
to say okay we'll do nothing until
Donald Trump is gone they're saying
let's just work together without Donald
Trump and without the United States and
that's exactly what this alliance is
allowing them to do now where the
cognitive dissonance comes in is when
the trumpets loudly don't care
what so-called liberal Europe wants or
does they don't care that were more and
more in the United States were more and
more not part of the conversation but
the United States suffers the
consequences of that and they still
won't blame Donald Trump so this is one
of those things Pat where if you
actually present what's going on - the
average trumpets they'll say that's good
we need to do what's best for us I don't
care what France wants I don't care what
Japan wants us to do but they'll never
realize that it's bad for the United
States geopolitically not to be part of
these alliances yeah and I certainly
worry too that it doesn't it doesn't
just stop with Trump like I think that
even if we elect a progressive in 2020
or you know even just a corporate
run-of-the-mill Democrat we're not gonna
be necessarily just allowed back into
these agreements because I think we've
tarnished tarnished our reputation so
significantly and the world community is
going to understand that the United
States isn't really accountable they'll
go from reflecting Democrats Republican
back to a Democrat to a Republican and
you know half the time we just can't
work with them why are we going to make
ten twenty thirty year long deals with
them if we can't anticipate what their
their politics is going to be like at
any given year
yeah and importantly you can identify
that the United States flips and flops
between Republican and Democratic
presidents that's one thing the other
problem is you can't count on the United
States as a reliable treaty or trading
partner because the Iran deal being a
perfect example without Iran having
violated it Donald Trump just says we're
pulling out of the Iran deal because he
doesn't like it and that's not a way
that you become a reliable a negotiating
partner trading partner working partner
geopolitically and I was thinking back
to November of 2016 and then again in
March of 2017 when we said is Germany
becoming the leader of the free world is
Angela Merkel effectively the leader of
the free world now that Donald Trump is
president of the United States that has
effectively been borne out and of course
half the trumpets don't care the other
half don't know and this is where we end
up and the entire we're gonna own the
libs stuff I mean it was a joke to begin
with and it's been an embarrassment and
Pat is completely right that if we elect
a different
president today Democrat Republican
doesn't matter we're talking about years
to undo the geopolitical damage that
Donald Trump has done make sure you're
following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show we
will take a quick break and be right
back after this with dr. John Gartner
one of today's David Pakman show
sponsors is east or built who's giving
everybody in our audience 20% off when
you go to East or built calm and use the
promo code Pakman and this part is
awesome they're also giving a portion of
each purchase to Planned Parenthood and
the ACLU if you've been thinking about
starting your own online store or
upgrading the one you have checkout East
store built it's a full-service set of
solutions they offer fully customized
web sites for your web store
instructional materials for improving
your web store low cost accounting
services for your web store one web
store created by e store bill was just
recognized by beheading calm as one of
the top 25 best web stores of 2019 East
store built has team members
specializing in everything from Shopify
to social media marketing they can help
your business establish as an LLC which
is a great way to help protect your
business from fraud and lawsuits their
team of certified public accountants can
take care of all your bookkeeping your
payroll your electronic timekeeping and
provide other accounting consulting
their accounting team is headed up by a
certified management accountant with
experience managing business budgets of
over 75 million dollars just go to East
store built calm I've put a link under
this video use promo code Pakman at
check out PA k man2 get 20% off your
entire order of e store startup products
and materials and if you're interested
in their affordable professional
accounting services just get in touch
with them using their website contact
form tell them David Pakman sent you and
you'll get 50% off your first month of
accounting services when you sign up for
a year subscription and don't forget
that they'll give a portion of all
purchases to Planned Parenthood and the
ACLU